أنا الآن أترك هانيو نيس بمشاعري
تشاركنا من جهة الفرح الكبير الذي لم نعد فيه
في فترة المذابح التي ذبحتنا وأساءت إلينا
وبدون رد والحمد لله دمر السيف لهم مساحة كبيرة
لقد قتلنا عشرات الآلاف منهم
أما العماليق، من ناحية أخرى، فلم يصبحوا جيشًا بعد
الأخلاقية وهذه هي الحرب الحقيقية لأمة إسرائيل بأكملها
البوابة استقرت في وقت لاحق بكل سهولة معنويا هو أن نفهم
الحاخام هو كائن مهم
ربما يكون جيدًا، ربما يكون قنبلة، لكنه مشبوه
من الأخلاقي إعدام جميع الإرهابيين من بعدي
إن التحقيق فيها هو أخلاقياً التغلب على كل شيء وتسويته
أجزاء أرض إسرائيل وكل مكان نغادره هناك نعم
سوف تنتقم الدبابير منا عاجلاً أم آجلاً
هذا هو المنقذ، يجب علينا أن نفهم ذلك بحكمة
قبل أن يشرحها لنا العدو بالدم
ولا سمح الله لنا ولجميع شعب إسرائيل بالتوفيق في الحملة
هذا الكبير والمهم
ال